Thank You mr. president if I could have
the first slide please so always and
that's what this slide is labeled is
goals of community mitigation really
highlighting that this begins in the
middle and the end with community this
community and the community of the
American people that are going to have
to do the things for the next 30 days to
make a difference I think you know from
that large blue mountain that you can
see behind me and I just want to thank
the five or six international and and
domestic modelers from Harvard from
Columbia from Northeastern from Imperial
who helped just tremendously it was
their models that created the ability to
see what these mitigations could do how
steeply they could depress the curve
from that giant blue mountain down to
that more stippled area in their
estimates they had between 1.5 million
and 2.2 million people in the United
States succumbing to this virus without
mitigation yet through their detailed
studies and showing us what social
distancing would do what people what
would happen if people stayed home what
would happen if people weren't careful
every day to wash their hands and worry
about touching their faces that what an
extraordinary thing this could be if
every American followed these and it
takes us to that stippled mountain
that's much lower a hill actually down
to 100 to 200 thousand deaths which is
still way too much